le le le commissaire a eu un bon mot
pour les pour les journalistes d'enquête
Alain ça ça ça conforte dans le travail
qu'on fait parfoisand o les résultats se
font attendre ça conforte où il faut
s'en méfier on sait jamais féitation on
reconnaî votre scepticisme qui fait de
un journal c'est ça 14 personnes est-ce
que c'est un gros coup pour l'UPAC parce
qu'on disait tout le temps quand est-ce
que quand est-ce qu'on va voir des
preuves concrètes que c'était une
Nutella est efficace ou pas ou qu'elle
don gros cou boisavien qui était quand
même aussi un bon premier coup ça ça
demeure c'est mascou a toutes sortes
d'allégations ailleurs à Montréal sur
des dossiers beaucoup plus gros où il y
a des enquêtes où il y a des
controverses où il y a des allégations
notamment le les compteurs d'eau le
faubourg contrecœur mais ça devient gros
par l'arrestation d'un mare évidemment
et surtout par Tony acurso qui est je
sais pas si c'est le plus gros au Québec
mais il est incontournable dans
l'industrie de la construction il y a il
y a des multiples allégations autour de
Monsieur acurso depuis 3 ans et demi
impliqué dans des controverses bon et
cetera et cetera alors le fait de
l'arrêter aujourd'hui donne euh donne
fait que c'est une grosse opération
depuis plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois il y a beaucoup de
rumeurs qui circulent sur ce coup qu'on
attendait de l'UPAC on le voyait
ailleurs ça arrive à Mascouche mais
évidemment l'impact est très gros alors
on peut peut-être faire le fil des
événements pour masscouche mais juste
avant d'entrer dans les détails de
Mascouche pour que les téléspectateurs
comprennent bien de quoi il s'agit moi
je me pose la question mais le lien
entre acursau et et Mascouche quel
est-il ben le
lien connu simple c'est un voyage
qu'aurait fait monsieur Marcotte le
maire de Mascouche ça lune de miel sur
le fameux touch de Tony acurso et moi
j'ai rencontré pas Tony acurso j'ai
rencontré vousz aimé
rencontrer il a toujours refusé on verra
quand ça arrivera donc j'ai intervie le
Mare Marcotte et il a jamais confirmé
mais ses silences sont très évoc